yeah let's go yeah let's
[Applause]
go Chang
gender let's go let's
go hey it's Lindsay and welcome back to
my closet almost exactly 1 year ago
today a new 18 was born it's me I'm 18 I
saw ATS perform for the first time and
from that moment on my life was changed
forever anyway that means they're here
today which means they're going to style
me which means cold red baby cold red is
youo going to sit by me we don't know
the seating placements yet I need to
change my phone background because it's
him what if he sees it anyway they need
no introduction a let's bring them in
maybe don't I'm sweating I need to put
deod on
yes hello
hi nice
you
hello
we hello my name is hello my name is
nice to meet you my name is Yo nice to
meet you hi I'm hi I'm will ni see you
hi I'm hi hello I'm M Welcome to My
Closet yay so beautiful so you guys are
going to be styling me for an entire
week and you get to choose what I do
each day you're pretty much controlling
my life okay who do you think will be
the best at doing this good confident
yeah can you each describe your personal
style in three words variety sick play
my style is
simple and HD for me it's just Hong Jong
okay okay Kim Hong I think simple is
best gender slender sick I'm very simple
I don't need so many color my style is
sexy
sexy every time how many buttons do you
open this is mingy you
know this isy do you have any questions
for me oh okay yeah what is your
favorite style I really like Y2K right
now and I like your necklace heart
necklace it's really pretty so you don't
have any fear about the
experience I don't these are all my
clothes your
clothes have a shopping
problem
hello your
concept wow let's
go we now shopping
yeah
it's my favorite brand it's
Sal oh it's cool shoes for shoes Sho
convers Converse
and she
took double shoes double p double
shoes Wow
Wow Let's Go
have fun on
starb this is starb look is
great happy Monday I forgot to ask him
about hair and makeup you know when
there's Idols just kind of standing in
front of you your mind just kind of kind
of just goes It goes I'm a little
nervous for this outfit just because I
don't know if those pants physically fit
under those
shorts oh no oh please fit please fit
I'm obsessed The Innovation the denim on
denim I would have never thought of this
myself this looks like one pair of pants
it's the Wang magic bab the fashion The
Innovation W young chose my number one
favorite activity which is getting
coffee my pumpkin try lot was good but
this outfit was the start of the show
I'm just so impressed of how sick this
look came together and if this is how
strong we're starting on Monday this
week's about to be crazy what do you
guys predict will be the next biggest
fashion
trend I think see through oh see- you're
already wearing see I always like
seethrough and then I like Chrome silver
silver is one of silver is
pretty hello I changed your
Tuesday oh hello I'm
s so what's the concept it's my
[Music]
star Monday Tuesday Wednesday thday
Friday Saturday suay is
this activity shopping
Department oh there see
through
serious it's coming
[Applause]
now time is running
sorry Tik Tok Tik Tok this is your
Tuesday look this is so this
just I really love
that or black L yay
it's Tuesday and I get to go shopping in
a killer outfit and if s wants me to
slay this hard on a Tuesday that's what
I'm going to do
SWA I'm a changed woman it's giving
expensive it's giving put it on Daddy's
credit card baby I love everything about
this look from the sunglasses to the
silver jewelry I was going to go thrift
shopping but I'm kind of debating if I
should go to Beverly Hills at this point
but I can't I can't afford that one so
Joyce and I lived out our white 2K movie
montage shopping
dreams shoes for mingy what you want
baby I also found the cutest dress of my
life look at it that's right bestie
spent
money I think you popped off a little
too hard on this one you've done
countless cool Concepts to support the
at storyline but if you could break away
from the pirate Universe what concepts
would you want to try I want to try just
only white shirts and only jeans a
simple Style I want try a funky
starro just retro star yeah and also I
think Barbies somay eight Barbies
in
yeah hi I'm you know I think lay is so
bright oh looks like blue sky blue sky
blue
sky Santa
mon Santa
mon just
simple thank
you
and
sneaker
s L's necklace saber heart this is L's
back
Wednesday is lens day
byebye ifs Chang
gender today's a special day for me if
you know you know I really I can't stop
giggling anyway doing my makeup bright
and glowy just like how he makes me feel
on the inside it look like a delicate
Little
Flower I love this it's elegant it's
cute it's summery a cream Lacy hat goes
with the laciness of the little shirt my
God that's so cute I genuinely cannot
stop smiling this look because I feel
like you know I'm going to go get for
runch I'm going to go to the beach I
can't believe this is happening to me
thanks you love you it's
you this outfit fit the Santa Monica
Vibe perfectly also look at those
pancakes today was so special because I
always used to compare yo to Sunshine oh
no and today was a perfect mix of blue
SK and
sunshine is there an accessory or
clothing item you guys can't live
without why the the earring for me I
have too many hores I am hand ring
twinkle twinkle and I think for Jung he
always we're watching
yes that's huge yes your is M M for
basic
item I'm Thursday I want to try very
simple maybe meet friend
you have so many F
[Music]
clothes you can do it keep going keep
going hurry up
oh oh white shirt oh white
shirt I like
[Music]
it
have fun with friends on Tuesday th
Thursday happy Thursday I think what's
so interesting about jungle's look is
his style is so clean and simple and
understated but then his vocals are like
the craziest Rockstar Vibes you could
possibly imagine so I just love the ju
position okay another sleigh I love the
bagginess the flowiness the just
carefreeness I feel like wind should be
flowing through my hair right now this
is the perfect clean girl aesthetic I
would literally say jungle and I are
like twins right now except for the fact
that my singing voice sounds like a
dying cat so met up with my besties and
we got some coffee Yes again I am a
caffeine addict we had the best day and
I felt so comfy so effortless and I will
definitely wear this look again thanks
chungle so your performance style is
very intense how do you manage to
perform in such elaborate outfits funny
I usually uh use many accessories so we
usually fix
[Music]
that
sex hello I'm mingy I will try Friday LS
concept is famous hot girl
oh everyone know Lind oh yeah L is in
the
town he
so Ming's favorite two mer accessor
ories last secret point oh what is it
oh is it good yeah it's really
sexy
[Applause]
okay this is Friday
L famous hot girl what do famous hot
girls do expensive airan smoothies no
boo clubbing I can do that one
existential crisis aside I think this
look is going to be
fire I don't think I've ever looked this
hot this look is Iconic this is giving
ultimate Rockstar don't with me I'm
honestly just kind of stressed out right
now because it's just like too good I
don't know where tonight's going to take
me but I'm ready for it I'm sweating
it's cuz I'm so hot name is hot girl
woohoo wow the paparazzi just came out
of nowhere Lindsay Lindsay lose your
bias how was ATS L can I get a photo I
heard that you brought the crop top back
how do you feel about that Jokes Aside
this fit was iconic and I had so much
fun Hong you've been known to upcycle
and customize your own clothes yes if
you had your own dream fashion brand how
would you describe it usually we go to
shop there is men's side and woman's
side but I don't want to make that I
think it would be there's no like no
gender I have three fashion icons my
order brother is one of the biggest
inspiration for me and also David Po and
also Olivier star you're my fashion ion
oh thank you so
much J this look for Saturday's CC con
to see
us let's go so first I choose the shoes
first cuz
in Kong she was stand for a long time
she have to dance with
us she was
first I love this jacket too twinkle
twinkle little you can do
it yeah let's go yeah let's go go let's
go this is K
girl oh
oh
and this is party for K con to see us
these days I really like the brown color
you can use this b or not this watch is
so cute so that's why I choose this one
is there
liy but this match with color with the
outfit a hair makeup leader car pinky
blush a headphone with a with this look
yeah been
nervous not only did a member of ATS
style me for their own concert it's the
captain of ATS I'm living in a dulu
dream and I'm not dulu I mean I am dulu
but like actually not today who is she I
don't feel like I've ever felt this
beautiful going to a K-pop
concert everything just flows perfectly
with the color scheme I look like the
light
stick uh-oh he said the belt was
optional obsessed with the vision but I
feel like it just doesn't need it I'm
just so excited and I get to see bouncy
live with the shoulders and
the got to kcon got fueled up then it
was ATS time I fully lost my mind I
think seeing bouncy life actually
changed my life I'm going to cry at
stage presence is powerful their talent
is unreal and I just felt really proud
and lucky to be an
at hello I'm
Sunday
very strong
color
oh oh
yeah your style me
too
[Music]
y hello happy Sunday what's crazy is
Yong and I share the exact same birthday
June 15th and this is a very lindsy
outfit so I think the Gemini and us
really connected wow I love it it's cute
it's sporty it really is giving grass
fields this outfit is so lindsy because
of all the blue and all the denim but
it's elevated Lindsay and it's
comfortable I think I might recreate
this outfit in the future not going to
lie all right let's go find a field
found the grass field sound's right this
outfit does look good on grass this was
probably the easiest Instagram photo
I've ever taken because I had the pose
locked in and the outfit look great
follow me on Instagram like comment
subscribe what is your advice to your
fans who might be struggling with their
self-confidence I just want to say that
nobody like you so just do doing your
thing yeah you're
pretty on
Monday my concept is go to gym go to
gy let's go let's
go I
love but I love all
[Applause]
Superstar and then oh cap yeah cap
because squirt and dead Lea is really
dangerous to top shoes so I choose this
FL
shes go to
gym how about makeup no makeup because
there are too many sweats he is the best
is really feet on you I think take care
of your bu yes
perfect do I gym absolutely not this
outfit looks classic it looks good the
only thing I'm worried about is my
physical strength so wow is she a gym
girly that's me lifting this is a great
look I mean obviously it's really
classic it's really simple but there is
a lot of thought into this we have the
black and white stripes with the
matching shoes even just the shoes
having traction on the bottom because he
cares that I'm safe there's no better
motivation to get me in the gym than a
cute outfit so this did the job it was
time to pump some
iron yeah I had no idea what I was doing
I'm more of a YouTube Pilates girl but
hey I got my heart rate up and I look
cute doing it this might have been one
of the best weeks of my life ATS are so
talented so sweet and now we know
they're great stylist too love you thank
you so much for watching and I I hope
you like our styling thank you thank you
so much
[Music]
bye